welcome to the next 25 i'm your host
dwyane wade and today i get an
opportunity to talk about the future for
some of the games brightest and best we
want to talk about what we call pipeline
but we're in this space right now where
you have individuals becoming famous
before they have driver's license
my daughter
she and she don't she even spoke too
many words and she was already famous
right what do you guys think about that
from the standpoint of the world that we
live in in sports that a young kid in
high school can become famous how do you
deal with that how do you handle that at
a young age i feel like nowadays
social media is is the top of the top
like everybody goes to social media to
look for things
and
guys now like are dunking that 13 14
years old man you you pull a dunk out in
the game at 13 14 they post it you go
viral they be having millions of
followers 500k
all these people comment commenting on
their life they got to live up to
expectations at such a young age they
come out rankings with kids at class of
20 27 2028 they're like how old is
you don't know what this kid can be
instagram famous
is real
my name is chris johnson better known as
nba master trainer i'm located here in
los angeles california
just because you're instagram famous
doesn't mean that you're prepared to
play in the wnba or nba if you really go
look at the track record of
people that have had success from a
social media period
and continue that success is very very
slim i think social media is going to be
around it's not going anywhere so it's
really important that we provide the
necessary tools
for for young players coming up to
understand that social media is their
new resume
is it good for our game though oh or is
it bad for like before i think it's i
think it's bad i think it goes back to
the highlight thing like you don't
actually know if something's good
because if you put together a highlight
reel like it's obviously going to be the
best stuff
and then like you know what i mean and
then they have especially the really
young ones they have all this pressure
and have like millions of people
disappointed in you because you're not
as good right at 13
or younger like that's hard i agree with
you i feel like it's a bad thing as
somebody's like not highly like
recruited like when you see that i feel
like that motivates you you know what
i'm saying like uh like when i see you
know kit like kids my age or younger
than me getting like all this all this
like love then that makes me want to go
harder you know what i'm saying like
that makes me like i want to i want to
be right there you know what i'm saying
so for me i think there's a good and a
bad to it but like the era that we grew
up in like ball is life hoop mixtape all
that stuff coming out with mixtapes kids
of a14 yeah like man like i gotta get in
the gym when i play i didn't see i
didn't get to see anybody yeah that's
not unless i see them on the person
right and so the game has evolved now
that you can see a 14 year old right
doing stuff you like i got to get on
that level i never seen that you know i
didn't know who was i heard some name
darius mouse i'm like who is darry's
mouths when he's st louis i don't i
don't know what that is i've never seen
him until i got a chance to play against
my play with him right now you can go on
and see you can see eight-year-old right
now that's gonna play in the league in a
couple years yeah okay yeah yeah
report my eighth grade year that's when
like that's when i first got on social
media cameras came to my games and
started recording me play
and then
i ended up getting an invite to like usa
and that's when my journey i guess began
to kick off after that when i came out
it was like you go to high school for
four years you go to college for four
years and then hopefully you get drafted
right and that's that is what someone
would have told me if i said how do i
get to the nba that's the path
if a kid come up to you guys today and
say what is the the easiest the most
secure path to get to the nba or to get
to the w what do you tell them it's time
to go to college
i feel like college gives you that
platform
where you can just really succeed i
always been at college right like when
they
told me about the gbs and said nine
doing that
they changed the whole trajectory of
what i want to do they put say they want
to put me at point guard different
things like that
me just playing defense being in that
system being long athletic being able to
show what i can do i think college the
traditional route
will still always be the dominant
maybe the safest route
because
of development
it takes so long for the true brain to
develop
some people are
um
they grow later
they develop later like their body
changes and
believe it or not if you look at a lot
of successful people
is not how fast they can get there it's
the journey i wasn't a highly recruited
kid growing up uh iowa state was my
first high major offer and i knew that's
where i was going right away all my
friends and family thought i was a red
shirt i ended up starting
every game besides the first game of the
season i got to go to usa with these
guys uh before my sophomore year and
that's when i was really like
i think i'm a pro i ended up going to
prep school once i went to prep school
at mount zion and in baltimore
everything changed i have no offers
before that dayton ended up uh
coming to watch me play and and gave me
a scholarship right then and there and i
was i went on a visit there and knew
right away like i belonged there but i
red shirt in my first year uh played
played my second year and then i went to
a nike skills academy camp once i went
to that camp i was like okay now i feel
like i got a chance to make it to the
next level i was a little more highly
recruited i got my first offer in eighth
grade to mizzou from missouri and i
wanted to like sign there right away i'm
like i got my first offer and i really
like credit my parents they did a great
job my dad's like we're gonna take all
our visits blah blah blah and when uconn
recruited me it was super exciting
because you know they're awesome but i
originally didn't want to go there
because they're so big i'm like i want
to beat uconn everyone goes there yeah
and then i took my visit there and they
convinced me
it was just like at that point i knew i
wanted to play in the w and they have so
many players there and they do so well i
knew i kind of treated like a business
thing like i knew going there was going
to get me to the next step that i want
to be at college outside of education
because some of y'all just go in for a
year and y'all out of there right you
only get no education uh
but i feel like you're learning how to
be an adult you're learning how to be on
your own you're learning how to wash
clothes you're learning like all the
things that you may some kids may have
may not have done by being at home with
their parents now you're learning it's
all on you and so before you get to the
nba level or the professional level
you you have learned some things about
how to be an adult honestly i feel like
college is the last time that you're on
a true team because when you get to the
league like you people traded mid-season
like you don't know if you're going to
be there from year to year like that's
the last time you feel like so a part of
something where you feel like you're so
in the trenches with that group of
people and when you get to that march
madness i think you know
that much money nothing like that
it's not like that college experience
yeah i'm saying like
yes like you talk you're talking about
like adult and all that stuff like yes
that is i am shocked that y'all said
everyone's like college college college
25 years from now
we'll be still seeing players go to
college where they're one and done
two two years and done or play all four
they will still have the same
opportunity
as the players that go on traditional
route and
the untraditional routes to me are in
still like a beta phase it's still
unknown
to
what the failure rate is
both routes
could
meet the end route
but i'm i'm still a traditional row
runner
uh because i believe that
young people need an opportunity to be
young
and some people can go to the
untraditional round maybe because of
circumstances
now you have g-league
right obviously you have overseas
you have ignite team
uh you can be like scotty and go to
seven high schools
we're given all these opportunities for
our basketball players to be able to you
know have an opportunity to reach their
dreams more than just going to college
for four years
how does this evolve where do we go from
here
oh i feel like i feel like resources now
is a lot different than it used to be i
feel like there's a lot more people in
this world that have the end on things
there's mentors that you can go to that
that know people that know people and
it's like i feel like nowadays it's just
a matter of who you know like you you
know the right person you're gonna be
good you're gonna and if you have talent
you don't you're gonna be real good with
the ignite program
you're gonna have to be
probably one of the top three four or
five players in your class
so it makes it
exceptional
and is geared around
about 10 players and that system is
truly
built for
player development
and
mental development i think there could
be
uh
a few more pathways i don't know when
the cba is up but
being able to go straight to the league
again you know i would like to see that
changed also
and
just so it can switch it up but that
that does put the curve in everything
once they change that college rule when
we get money in ill deal it's way
different now i'll be watching my
brother get all these deals at kentucky
i'm like
can i get something when i was in
college i'm rationing my per diem check
shout out jacob thompson
so is that where we're going where the
nba is not the all in be all
or the w right or like it's like kids
growing up is like the w is still young
so it's still growing right the nba is
kind of older so it's kind of like oh i
can make money i don't need to go to the
league to make money i can make money in
high school i think that's where i was
going before the nil deal like i heard a
lot of people talking about playing
overseas instead of going to college and
then we can't go into the draft until
we're like 22.
but now with the deals you can make
money there i don't know if it's gonna
change with the nil
um
with your ability to be paid off of your
own personal brand and likeliness you're
gonna see a lot of people not make it to
the nba because
they're being paid a lot earlier
and
that can actually
take away from
the hunger dependent on the individual i
don't think making it to the nba is the
nbr it's something that you want
i work with the best players in the
world and some people that make an
extreme amount of money playing
basketball
they still get up
five o'clock am they still get up
and do it over and over again you have a
better chance at doing other things than
making it
uh in the nba and that's how special
those guys are to that craft
and
that's how special they are
to being on that stage and being able to
perform
[Music]
you